according to white house propagandists
we are in the midst of the greatest
economic recovery in the history of the
world
according to our lying eyes the economy
is in the gutter
according to america's first quarter
economic numbers
our lying eyes are right
gdp first look first quarter is a nasty
minus 1.4 minus
1.4 we haven't had a minus sign since
that nasty second quarter coveted
related in 2020 let's go through it
consumption drops to 2.7 well below
expectations although sequentially it's
actually higher than last time which was
2.5
the pricing index buckle up 8
8
that is unbelievable to find a higher
number than 8 percent you have to go
back to 1981
and if you look at the personal
consumption expenditure quarter over
quarter that was up 5.2 now that isn't
so bad because the high water mark there
is actually 6.1 from june of last year
and that took us back to 1980
so gdp is way up
sorry gdp is way down
prices are way up household spending is
way up each of those things separately
very bad together absolutely terrible
cnbc is reporting these numbers as
unexpected
it's always unexpected when liberal
economic policies fail
it's not unexpected by me
it's not unexpected
by you
but to the supposed experts it is always
unexpected just like it's always
unexpected when conservative economic
policies work
so that's cnbc's line unexpected
aberration totally weird
the new york times is taking a different
tack to cover for the biden
administration
and that is to say that the dismal
economic numbers
are actually
a good thing
breaking news reports the new york times
the u.s economy shrank in the first
quarter but the numbers may mask the
recovery's resilience
the gdp
has collapsed the record inflation the
soaring gas prices the soaring food
prices
that's all just an illusion you see
great and glorious leader joe biden is
secretly taking care of all the people
and he is the greatest and most popular
president in the history of the world
and he won 85 bazillion votes
we all joke about the absurd propaganda
that comes out of north korea comes out
of china comes out of russia
pravda at the height of the soviet union
had nothing on the new york times
actually
the new york times was also covering for
the soviets at the height of the soviet
union
i have bad news for you and the fact
checkers can censor me for saying it if
they want to but it's the truth
the economy is not in recovery joe
biden's policies have been catastrophic
and none of this is unexpected
in fact you can mark my prediction now
before biden's economy gets better you
can expect it to get a whole lot worse
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from conversion
ninjas who said the teacher union's next
push will be smaller classrooms in the
form of windowless vans filled with
candy i think that's probably a pretty
good guess given the way things are
going with some of that brilliant
content in the classroom
speaking of those sorts of things i
i actually i do
want to talk to you about how to
relax
chill out let all the stress of this
crazy political cycle just melt away
when you go to sleep on your beautiful
helix mattress right now go to
helixsleep.com
knowles and enter my boudoir and take a
little looksie at my bed
sit down please enter to my bed but
actually not my bed that's kind of the
whole point you shouldn't be sleeping on
a bed that was made for someone else you
are unique you deserve a bed that was
made for you helix can do it helix sleep
has a quiz that takes two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why buy one made for
someone else with helix you know that
you're getting a mattress made for the
way that you sleep whether you prefer a
soft mattress a medium mattress a firm
mattress whether you want to be cooled
down a little bit because you sleep a
little bit hot whether you've got some
spinal alignment issues maybe you want a
plus size mattress for plus size
sleepers helix has it for you they will
match you to the perfect mattress
mattress comes right to your door comes
shipped no big deal if you do not like
it they've got a 10 year warranty you
can try it out for a hundred nights
you're gonna love it though so none of
that even matters helix is offering up
to two hundred dollars off all mattress
orders two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com knowles
that's helixsleep.com
canadawles
the disinformation
is
at least as
intense as anything we've ever seen in
the world but it's not coming only from
tin pot dictators on the other side of
the globe it's coming from the new york
times
economy
looks like it's in terrible shape
according to every single metric but
actually that is good news for joe biden
really good news strong joe biden
recovery at the very same time that the
white house has established a
disinformation board if the white house
really were going to establish an actual
disinformation board that were out to
suppress disinformation the new york
times would not exist today
the new york times would the entire
newspaper would be disbanded the
building would be reduced to rubble they
would salt the earth where the building
once stood
but the disinformation board that the
white house is setting up is not really
seeking to stop disinformation the
disinformation board is seeking to
spread disinformation and stop true
information from getting out the way we
know this is because the woman who was
named to lead the disinformation board
was a major purveyor of disinformation
during the 2020 election this woman
propagated the claim that the hunter
biden laptop was
not legitimate was russian
disinformation it wasn't real and all
the evidence of the biden families
crimes
nothing to see here was totally fake
please ignore it turned out that wasn't
true now even
the liberals will admit
that the under biden laptop was totally
legit there are some legitimate
questions about
hunter's dealings in ukraine hundreds of
dealings in china
and more importantly joe biden's
dealings in those places the ten percent
equity that was being kicked back to the
big guy the five million dollars more
than five million dollars discrepancy on
joe biden's financial disclosures
they'll admit that now after the
presidential election when it doesn't
matter but at the time the woman leading
the disinfo board today was pushing all
of that disinformation gensake was just
asked about this a reporter said hey
hold on isn't it a little weird that
you've got this peddler of disinfo
running the disinfo board gensake
have much of an answer
she had previously called the hunter
biden laptop a trump campaign product um
seeming to discredit its validity or
validity of reporting surrounding that
um how can can you assuage concerns of
people who are looking at this person
who's been appointed to this position
and wondering if she's going to be able
to accurately judge misinformation now
that a lot of that reporting has been
proven to be
factual in some ways well i don't have
any comments on the laptop but what i
can tell you is that it sounds like the
objective of the board is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities i'm not sure who opposes
that effort
even jenn saki's response is
disinformation because what she said is
obviously not true
she said one i'm not going to talk about
the laptop because it exposes the
corruption of my boss so i'm just not
going to talk about it even though it's
a very important news story
but but two she says well look
it sounds like the purpose of the board
is to stop disinformation it doesn't
sound like that at all
if it if it sounded like that then the
person picked to lead the board would
not be one of the big peddlers of
disinformation which is the point of the
question so what it sounds like to me is
that the point of the board is to
encourage disinformation which means
suppressing conservatives suppressing
real true news stories and just spouting
the party line from the the ruling class
that's what it sounds like to me and i
don't know who would ever oppose that
you you're the ones opposing that that's
what you're doing
you are the people that you are accusing
of spreading disinformation and you know
it she knows it she's not a stupid woman
jen zaki
i i don't know i can't really speak to
joe biden he doesn't seem like he's got
all of his marbles and he was never the
brightest bulb in the shed to mix
metaphors but the people who are running
the establishment
they're not stupid people mayorkas at
dhs the
army of faceless bureaucrats who run who
run the actual government
they're not they're not stupid people
they know what they're doing and they
know what the effect of this will be is
it any coincidence that they announce
the
disinformation governance board what
three days after elon musk announces
that the libs aren't going to have a
complete and total monopoly on big tech
previously the libs had a total monopoly
over the flow of information around the
country then elon musk comes in and he
says i'm going to give conservatives
free speech three days later the
government says yeah we're gonna have a
disinformation board
that's a coincidence i don't think so
speaking of disinformation and speaking
of my predictive powers
the the dark magic of nostradamus
predicting the future
yesterday on this show i talked about
how one of the silliest lines in public
discourse is this line when people who
have seventeen thousand vaccines and
booster shots and took the jab and you
know they're really bought in on the
whole covid regime and then they
contract covid which they weren't
supposed to do if they got the vaccine
remember fauci wallenski biden all said
if you get the vaccine you won't catch
covid and you won't spread covet either
and then what happens
they catch kovid and then the line they
always use is
well thank goodness i got the vaccine
say why you got covet they said no well
it would it would have been a lot worse
if i didn't have the vaccine
what do they base that on pretty much
nothing so maxine waters tested positive
for kovid we wish her a speedy recovery
here's what she said today i've received
a positive test result for covid i'm
currently isolating and have no symptoms
just like most people who catch covet
has no symptoms at all i am following
all protocols as recommended by the
office of the attending physician in cdc
guidance i'm grateful to be fully
vaccinated
to receive two booster shots
thankfully i'm feeling fine and
recommend everyone get vaccinated if
you've not done so already
so
call me old-fashioned but when i was
growing up uh what a vaccine meant was a
vaccine was a medical intervention to
prevent you from contracting a malady
that's that's what the definition of a
vaccine is and that's what our entire
ruling class promised us that this
vaccine was going to do for covid and
then that didn't happen the vaccine
didn't actually do that and so they
changed their story and they said that a
vaccine actually does not seek to stop
you from contracting or spreading a
virus it just seeks to mitigate the
symptoms which is not what a vaccine is
that you could call that a
pre-contraction therapeutic
you could call it medicine you take
before you catch the thing
but you can't what what they are
spreading is very silly
misinformation
they're not persuading anybody
our genius ruling liberal elites are not
persuading anybody
that's why they've got to control the
narrative that's why they've got to
censor conservatives that's why they've
got to control the algorithms on social
media that's why they've got to control
the establishment news media and
hollywood they have to do it because
they're not really persuading anyone and
so their views are not going to become
popular organically if they can ever
become popular at all they it has to be
done by force this is why the minute
that conservatives get even a little
foothold
into social media the whole narrative
shifts
this actually began in the early days of
social media in the very early days the
late 2000s
and then early 20 teens conservatives
absolutely crushed it on social media
because they'd been kept out of the
establishment media for so many decades
at the moment that there was a chance
for conservatives to spread a message it
spread like wildfire and then
this led
pretty much directly to donald trump
getting elected president he was sort of
memed into the presidency and right
after that all the libs lobbied the big
tech companies and they said you can't
let this happen again conservatives are
doing too well on your platform they
suppress the conservatives elon
announces that he's going to take over
twitter and make it fairer for
conservatives overnight conservative
accounts jump by leaps and bounds i've
gained something like 80 000 followers
in the past
few days on twitter and it's not just
bots it's people engaging with me it's
blue checkmarks who are verified humans
just the moment that conservatives get
any
shot at a fair break
the message spreads much more clearly
why because look at the spokesman
who who the left has
not only are the claims that they're
making preposterous they're saying the
economy is in recovery when we all go to
the gas tank we all or the gas pump
rather we all go to the grocery store we
all see that the economy is not doing
great
we they say that immigration is just
fine we know it's not fine we've got
millions of people pouring over the
border they say foreign affairs are much
better thank goodness the adults are in
charge what are you talking about we
have the first major war in europe since
world war ii
we see
facts on the ground things are not going
well education is great oh yeah because
you're transiting five-year-olds so i
don't think that's great you're reading
porn to little kids in elementary school
i don't think that's great
you're telling white kids that they're
evil
by virtue of their race
through critical race theory i don't
think that's great
parents don't think that that's great
around the country so
we see the facts on the ground but then
just look at their spokesman
you've got joe biden he is the most
prominent democrat in the country
president of the united states here is
the kind of soaring periclean rhetoric
that we're getting from president joe
biden
i'm also sending to congress
a comprehensive package
of that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs uh and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
now you know what the democrats do when
joe biden just stumbles over his own
words has no idea what he's saying can't
pronounce certain words
uses words in a way that don't make any
sense whatsoever repeats himself within
the very same breath when they when he
does all of that when he shows obvious
signs of cognitive decline
the libs say oh well you know that's his
childhood stutter
that's what they say they they trotted
this line out during the 2020
election and specifically the democrat
national convention in 2020 they had to
explain joe biden's obvious senility and
so they said well it's because of this
childhood stutter
and the libs just went with that they
said yes it's the childhood stutter i
actually i had liberal friends and
relatives tell me they said no michael
you know what we hear is that's just the
way joe biden always was
what are you talking about biden's been
in politics for 50 years you know what
he always was did you forget so soon
this is obviously a market change they
say no no just a childhood stutter what
a childhood stutter that disappeared for
70 years and then just came back in the
man's late 70s
roaring with a vengeance no of course
not that's
insane it cannot be overstated
how dramatic the cognitive decline of
joe biden has been in recent years just
to compare it i'm just picking a clip at
random there's a clip that was going
around the internet this is joe biden 20
years ago yelling at a u.s marine while
he was senator from delaware the context
actually doesn't really matter listen to
this man and tell me that the only thing
that's wrong with joe biden today is a
cognitive is a is a childhood stutter
i respectfully suggest they have
responsibilities slightly above your pay
grade
slightly above your pay grade
to decide whether or not to take the
nation to war alone
or to take the nation the war part way
or to take the nation to war half a
halfway
that's a real tough decision that's why
they get paid the big bucks that's why
they get the limos and you don't
i mean this sincerely i'm not trying to
be flip
because i think and that's why i was set
at the outset the reason why i'm glad
you did what you did
we should come to our milk
we should make a decision
but in terms of whether the secretary of
state
has
no more to consider than you do as the
arms inspector
you didn't get in didn't get my job done
get me in
period you made the deal right that's
the deal a deal's a deal get me in scott
ritter i'm ready to go
it's not how it works
so joe biden
is the same nasty man that he's been his
whole career we kind of forget that
because he's he's created this image
really the the establishment media have
created this image of nice old happy
uncle joe licking an ice cream cone and
he's not a nice guy he's a very very
nasty man who's done very nasty things
throughout his career and he always uses
weird phrases that's nothing new either
got to come to our milk okay we got it
and so
those sort of weird colloquialisms folky
sayings that has been part of joe's
career too
but that's not what we're seeing when
joe biden says the then the russian
yachts and the kleppy cla kleptum who's
winona ryder and the
uh anyway bad guys huh when he does that
it's it's not a stutter that's happening
okay it's not just some lifelong speech
affliction that he's had it's because
he's in clear clear cognitive decline
he's got one one thousandth the energy
today that he had 20 years ago forget 20
years ago five years ago six years ago
during the biden administration or
during the obama administration rather
when he was the vice president
biden had much more
energy and acuity he's never been the
brightest bulb in the pack but he at
least had a kind of political sharpness
that's gone
that's totally gone and he seems
vacant he seems very much
in trouble
so he's just a vessel he's an empty suit
to
run the show at the whims of the liberal
establishment and things are not going
very well as a result
and the lib the libs are they seem happy
about it they say no it's actually a
good thing it's it's a good thing
that your gas prices are way up it's
actually a sign of a strong economy when
you really think about it when you
really think about it in the long term
mark ruffalo the liberal actor
is making this argument explicitly he's
saying the high gas prices that's a good
thing he's going even further he's
saying the war in ukraine
is a gift to joe biden because that'll
spike the price of gas and that will
give biden an opportunity to move to a
green agenda
this is a moment for president biden to
take
this
um
our momentum
people's fear um their disgust with the
war they're discussed with energy prices
and and and use that to solidify a
message to the american people that now
is the time to transition this is where
the jobs are that's where national
security is and we are going to keep
pushing him to do it and this is a this
is a gift from the president as we see
it and we see him uh accepting it in
such terms
this is a gift now did mark ruffalo
consciously mean to say
that it's a it's a good thing that
ukrainians are dying and russian
soldiers i guess too but did he did he
mean to say it's a good thing that
thousands and thousands of people are
dying because now we can fight the sun
monster
no i don't think consciously he meant to
say that but that's what he said
that's what that means this war in
ukraine it's a gift
it's a gift and biden can really make
the most of it that's what he's saying
what he's saying
is something that
liberals
have
said and believed for a very long time
which is that
people are the problem
which is that nature whatever we mean by
nature is much more important than
people the traditional view of our
relationship to the created world is
that we are stewards of it that the
world is for us for our delight and we
have to be responsible stewards of that
and what the left has done is flipped
that entirely according to the left we
are not the highest of creation such
that we the birds of the air and the
fowl and the fish of the sea that that's
all for us
no they've flipped it such that human
beings are parasites on the earth we're
destroying nature
the the animals and the trees they're
not for us we need to serve them
we're a plague we've got to thin out our
numbers we've got to stop doing stuff
and you know if if some people get
killed so that gas goes up and increases
more suffering for people who can't heat
their homes and who can't fill their gas
tanks well hey that actually that's
probably a pretty good thing because
that'll force the people to move to
solar energy or windmills or whatever
that's
what they really believe and it's not
because of any scientific argument or
anything like that it's just because
they don't like people they care a lot
about humanity in the abstract but they
don't care about actual people they it
comes down to as simple
a an idea as that conservatives
pro-human
pro-people on lots of issues on abortion
on environment environmentalism on
everything on the family and the left
anti-people
there's a woman who's gone viral
a pro-abortion activist who's gone viral
uh thanks of course to our friends at
libs of tick tock for
for
defending the use
of aborted babies
to make
biofuel
aborted babies being burned and then
used for electricity the real answer to
that question is nobody really cares
actually you could bake them fillet them
frequency them barbecue
roast
you could broil them pan fry them i do
not care
and let's be honest here if we could
burn those suckers for actual like
lights and power i feel like we're on to
something
you guys are so anti-solar
here you go
it's a resource we're gonna have no
matter what
but i mean really though
that this this is what you guys are
pushing now they're burning fetuses for
fuel
i mean it's better than going into a
landfill though right
so this demon is making some conflicting
arguments here the first point is she's
doubting the veracity of what that
pro-life activist at the top is saying
namely that abortion activists are
sending
aborted babies to bio-waste facilities
to be turned into biofuels she says
you're that's your line now you're
saying that's really happening yes that
that is really happening that had i can
at least say that has happened i am
strongly inclined to believe that that
is still happening but at the very least
even liberal media outlets very
established liberal media outlets i've
got the cbc right here have admitted
that it has happened
tissue fetal tissue
aborted babies have been sent to bio
waste processing facilities
to be turned into energy that has
happened
okay so just on her factual claims yes
that is happening and then she says well
i don't care if it's happening that's
fine by me that's good isn't that better
than going to a landfill
i don't know if it's better or worse
than than sending
aborted babies to a landfill i think
they should be buried and be given
they should be given funerals because
they've been killed and they're people
and people deserve funerals and just
like when your grandma or grandpa die
you're not going to leave them in the
streets to be eaten by dogs and you're
not going to send them to some dystopian
facility to power your televisions at
just like you would treat them with
respect because we recognize that there
is something sort of sacred about a
human body
so too we should do the same thing with
aborted babies
innocent little babies who have been
killed and then she says the line to be
provocative she says i don't care what
you do with them i don't care fricasee
them saute them fry them up i don't what
do i care
and she's trying to be provocative sure
but i i suspect she really believes this
because her argument is it rests
entirely on denying that the babies are
babies
they're not really human well of course
they're human what do you think they are
platypuses no well they're not really
individuals of course they're
individuals they have individual dna
they have they have
individual human processes outside of
the mother even when they're connected
by an umbilical cord they have separate
individual human processes well they're
not really alive of course they're alive
that's why you have to kill them in
order to have an abortion
if they're not alive then you don't
worry don't have the abortion and
nothing will happen right then no of
course what will happen is they will
continue to grow and then they will be
born because they're alive
so so her argument rests on denying that
and saying well it's just a clump of
cells i don't care whatever
fry them frequency them
you sometimes hear this argument with
regard to eating dogs
we all know there's something wrong
about eating dogs there's just something
kind of wrong about it i don't even like
dogs i'm a people person but i would not
want to eat a dog
it seems something wrong about eating an
animal that has
grown and been trained to be man's best
friend to trust human beings and then we
turn on them and eat them and kill them
that would be that seems wrong to me
how much more wrong how infinitely more
wrong would it be to do that sort of
thing to human beings but if you have no
respect for
human dignity for
the moral order for the the idea that
humans are more than just flesh and
blood there are more than just big sacks
of chemicals that we actually have souls
and spirits and that there are things in
this world namely everything that really
matters to us our hopes our dreams our
loves or joys that are beyond the
material world
if you if you deny all of that then yeah
i guess her argument makes sense it's
just unfortunately it's just completely
wrong you're seeing this kind of
radicalism from not just kooks on tick
tock but from elected democrats and
democratic candidates
john fetterman lieutenant governor of
pennsylvania democrat candidate for
senate he just said there should be no
limits on abortion
if i'm in the united states senate i
would immediately support the first
campaign to support the elimination of
the filibuster to make sure that we
codify
women's reproductive freedom
in law to make sure that even if the
supreme court does go down that road and
eliminate or revoke roe v wade that we
already existingly codify that into law
and make sure that we can't go back
abortions are going to continue in
america whether it's legal or not they
just won't be safe if they're illegal
and we can't ever go back to that we
just can't and are there any limits on
abortion you would find appropriate i
don't believe so
so this guy is either stupid or
dishonest or maybe he's both
his argument doesn't make sense
philosophically you could say well home
burglaries are going to happen in
america so we can either do it in a safe
way
where we don't where the homeowner is
not allowed to protect himself and they
roll out the red carpet for him or we
can do it in a dangerous way where
people might get hurt so it's going to
happen you're never going to stop that i
guess it's going to happen but when you
pass laws against things you get less of
those things that's what the law does
some utopians say otherwise they say you
get more of
a certain behavior when you outlaw it
but that's not really true you get less
of it
we need safe abortions there's no such
thing as a safe abortion because every
abortion kills a baby and and a lot of
abortions imperil the lives of women
and when abortion became legal you had a
lot more abortions the kind of
radicalism there should be no limits
whatsoever he says
up until the very moment of birth no
limits whatsoever you want to talk about
disinformation forget about this guy
this guy's adult even though he does
wield some political power
a cbs has has an abortion reporter her
name is kate smith i'm sorry they had an
abortion reporter named kate smith she
was supposed to be the disinterested
reporter not opinion columnist reporter
covering abortion in america she's going
to go now and work at planned parenthood
she's going to go be the top
propagandist for planned parenthood now
the biggest abortion mill in america
now
i'm not even specifically knocking her
here for supporting abortion though she
should be knocked for that right she
should be criticized for support that is
evil in and of itself but there's a
further problem here which is she
pretended to be a disinterested
journalist
for years
but in our totally unbiased
disinterested mainstream media outlets
like cbs news
and she's not she she literally is a
propagandist for planned parenthood
that's disinformation the next time i
hear about those brave intrepid
reporters the fourth estate speaking
truth to power they're not they're
pravda they're pravda they they make
pravda look like school boys okay
they are
as as preposterous
sort of propagandists that you see in
north korea okay and here in the united
states what a shame that is that we have
to say that you know at the daily wire
we're trying to fight back we've started
our own publishing wing it's called dw
books
we are really happy to publish books
that actively fight the left's monopoly
on storytelling such as
fiery but mostly peaceful the 2020 riots
and the gaslighting of america by julio
rosas in it julio exposes the black
lives matter riots that broke out across
the country in the aftermath of george
floyd's death for the sham that they
were
roses who was reporting from the ground
gives his first hand experience and
illuminates the media's attempts to
convince americans that the fatal and
destructive riots were
peaceful check out the trailer
the media guest gas-lit the american
people for all of 2020 as the riots
unfolded they did not give you the full
story
i was there george floyd kyle
rittenhouse rachard books jazz in
seattle i saw all the riots with my own
eyes windshields being smashed giant
rocks that were being from businesses
that were starting to be looted the
crowd started to become hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
i experienced the tear gas i experienced
the smoke
this was very real to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests cnn with that chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe your lying eyes because they
were trying to appease a very dedicated
antifa movement that's there we read my
book fiery but mostly peaceful you will
get the full story you will learn what
actually happened during the riots of
2020 and what the media did not want to
tell you by my book fiery but mostly
peaceful everywhere books are sold
the book is available for pre-order
right now on amazon or anywhere you buy
books online so head on over to
pre-order your copy today we'll be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in the
mailbag first question up from bridgette
dear mr knowles my name is bridget first
off thank you for everything you do
i am a huge fan of what you say and the
points that you state in politics and
how it is tied with faith that being
said i need advice on dating everybody
does
i'm waiting for marriage
it has been nearly impossible to meet
someone with the same values that i
believe in especially with the guys at
my college in the hookup culture there
is one guy who has the same beliefs as
me who attends the newman center on
campus that's a catholic center on
campus i want to at least get to know
him especially since i've had a crush
since i first met him the dilemma is
that i have never talked to him he
doesn't really know my name and he's
older than me so he'll be graduating
sooner than i will should i say hi to
him before the end of the semester or
should i be patient to see if he does
first
asking for a hopeful answer from a
hopeless romantic no don't be hopeless
yes you should you should go introduce
yourself and say hello
come on go ahead and do it first of all
i wouldn't be at all surprised if this
guy wants to talk to you too and he's
just a little shy and he's just a little
nervous and you know young men in
general can suffer from a lack of
confidence sometimes and also with the
craziness of our dating scene these days
he might he might not exactly know how
to do it but sure go do it what have you
got to lose
just go up introduce yourself say hey
back in my single days i liked it when
girls would come up and say they liked
me
so do it go for it why not what have you
got to lose what do you have what do you
have to gain oh i don't know a husband
and a family and a good life and what do
you have to lose i don't know he's not
interested you don't get a cup of coffee
and you move on from steve i have a
relationship question which feels
strange to write
i'm married oh
i'm married in my 30s and have a solid
job my question is when it comes to my
female co-workers when is flirting
appropriate for someone in my position
i've never crossed any physical lines
good and flirting often feels like the
female version of guys joking around and
bashing each other in a locker room uh
like when they're friends however
i also realize there is always a point
at which anything can turn from
appropriate to sinful what are your
thoughts on flirting with people while
in a relationship and where is the line
thanks
really really good question
i am of sicilian extraction as i may
have mentioned once or twice
we are known traditionally as some of
the most flirtatious people in the world
i also come from new york new yorkers
have a reputation of being a little bit
flirtatious okay so i think that can be
perfectly fine all right that can
actually be a sort of lovely aspect of
life
but it has to be couched within
real standards and the standard that i
would recommend to you is the standard
of chivalry
okay there's a line i'm going to take
this in kind of a weird direction
there's a line in edmund burke it's
probably the most famous line in edmond
burke's reflections on the revolution in
france he is
long credited with being the the founder
of modern conservative political
philosophy
edmund burke is describing marie
antoinette
and he says uh it is 16 or 17 years
since i saw the
queen of france then the dauphinus at
versailles
and
surely never lighted on this orb a more
delightful vision
uh shirley never lighted on this orb
which she hardly seemed to touch a more
delightful vision and he goes on to talk
about how awful it is that the radicals
would go after marie antoinette he
should have thought that a thousand
score swords must have left from their
scabbards to avenge even an insulting
look at marie antoinette now is that him
being licentious and lustful after marie
antoinette is that him thirst posting
the queen of france or being unfaithful
to his wife or anything like that no
no it's not but it's couched within
chivalry
two you're talking about the workplace
keep it buttoned up at the workplace
just as a general rule you should be
even more restrained at the workplace in
general
back in the old days when there weren't
a whole lot of women in the workplace
when it was mostly kind of a boys club
you could be a little looser maybe with
your language you could be a little
looser with your behavior but when
you're in mixed company generally it's
an important thing to do to to keep
things together and two
uh you don't want to end up in front of
hr so i would keep that relatively
buttoned up and then three
you
you kind of tip your hand here a little
bit which is you say nothing's gotten
physical
whoa buddy there's a bit you know look
if you go up to some lady on the street
say that's a beautiful dress
that that doesn't need to imply any
anything about your
sexual desire for that woman you might
just say oh you're looking lovely today
that's that's a wonderful thing to say
but if you're saying now look i haven't
let anything get physical now now you're
implying something else now you're
implying
okay i really have a strong desire for
this woman and that
that's not a good thing i would uh
i say this even as
you know man from the same culture as
giacomo casanova
i would err on the side of caution from
whiskey rebel
hey michael i'm a long-time listener and
a first-time subscriber my wife and i
have been married for seven years and
have three children together we're
florida residents and the parental
rights and education bill
and disney's response have led us to
having some intense though not heated
discussions around the content that our
kids are consuming from disney she
doesn't believe any of this warrants
completely excising disney from our
lives and still wants to take the kids
to disney world and and let them watch
their content
and have an overall disney childhood
like we had
her solution
is just only let them watch content that
we approve of
i believe the disney childhood we wanted
for them cannot happen so long as disney
overly pushes a sexual ideology into
their kids entertainment and theme parks
what would you do in my situation thanks
for all you do ps came for ben state for
knowles thanks man you're a man of
excellent taste obviously and you're
right
and your wife is wrong
we were just debating this in in our own
household and uh i wouldn't even say we
were debating i guess we were on the
same page and then one day i'm at work
and i get an email your disney plus
subscription has been canceled i just
knew it was my wife made the executive
decision we're not doing this the reason
that it's going to be really hard
i'm not saying don't show your kid
fantasia or something but the reason
it'll be hard to raise your kid on a
steady diet of good old disney
but not new disney is that the the point
of these
cartoon
childhood universes is that you you
develop an attachment to the characters
so then you want to see the characters
and everything else so disney you know
mickey mouse 50 years ago was a great
wholesome cartoon
disney and mickey mouse today is pushing
transgenderism the kid is not going to
be able to distinguish between good old
mickey mouse and new creepy weird
pervert mickey mouse
so i would just recommend
more or less cutting out disney
i'm not saying don't show the kid
pinocchio i'm not saying a movie hero
there but
i wouldn't make your kid a disney kid
i would i would look for something else
because that's how they get you that's
how the left always gets you they go
into institutions that are important
that have prestige that have a long
legacy that people are attracted to and
then they pervert those institutions and
they they play on people's
affection for that institution and
that's exactly what they're doing at
disney and it's powerful they do it
because it works so you've got to watch
out for that from disney
from disney from christina hi michael
what is your advice for dealing with
people who refuse to see those of us who
chose not to get vaccinated now that
there is less segregation between vaxxed
and unvaxed because most of the mandates
have been dropped it seems that it is
now socially acceptable for liberals to
associate with us again however i still
don't feel comfortable after being
ostracized for so long what's the best
way to move forward thanks
yeah move forward move on i'm not saying
in general lib society you can
you can say look i don't want to go join
your stupid club or i don't want you
know for people who are just the average
lib who ostracized you in society
but if you talk about your friends and
family and they went through some
neurotic break during kovid because they
believed dr fauci as a lot of people did
a lot of a lot of gullible people
believed the lab coats because they
spoke from a position of authority even
though they were wrong about pretty much
everything
and you were fortunate that you knew
better than to follow these very corrupt
people who were running our country um
but you know if if because of their
neurosis they didn't want you over for
thanksgiving another saying come back
over and it's your friend of your family
just go back over
i'm not the kind of guy that holds a
grudge life's too short just move on
it's good you get your friend back
that's fine they went through a thing
they maybe came out the other end that's
okay
from camille
hey michael i have another dating
question i recently told a story about a
guy i kind of dated in college ain't
that ain't that the story of college you
kind of dated we were in the same friend
group and tried dating at the end of my
sophomore and senior years both times i
moved back home when school ended and
felt like he wasn't right for me i
basically told him that i just wasn't it
just wasn't working for me and that we
make better friends however after
telling this story to some of my guy
friends i received a lot of backlash and
was called heartless so my question is
did i not end things well i thought by
not leading him on i was being nice and
what is the best way to end things with
a guy sincerely chilling with my jar of
hearts yeah i would i'd just be clear
say yes you know man i'm just not
interested
clarity is a lot better the only thing i
think you did wrong is you dated him
twice so what happened you dated the
first time you realized you didn't like
him that much
and then what you got bored and you
started dating him again because nothing
better was right you know that's not a
good thing to do i wouldn't recommend
that that kind of ambiguity is not not
really nice to him but
if you're if you're going to say hey
look we tried it we dated a little it's
not this isn't it then you know move on
it's okay free him up he can go find
another girl you might be sad but
whatever you can pretend that you'll
remain friends but you almost certainly
won't and then you move on and find a
hunk you know that's just the way that's
just the way these things go from jacob
hey michael
i really enjoy the show thank you i
recently just graduated early from the
university of delaware since then i've
been contributing to society as an
engineer unfortunately my family all
wants to go see me graduate and joe
biden is the guest speaker
i feel like it's not worth going since
i've been out of school for some time
now but my parents and grandparents
still want me to go even if it means
they have to sit through abiding speech
i really don't want to listen to a biden
speech either especially if i have to
take a day off work any thoughts on the
matter sincerely if only the daily wire
hired mechanical engineers yeah i don't
know with all the rain in nashville
maybe we'll need some soon
you should go to your graduation
it's not just about you it is about your
parents it is about your grandparents
you should go you should especially go
because the president is speaking i
think this guy is a big dummy and
extremely corrupt and i don't want to
listen to him say a single word either
and i'm not convinced he can articulate
a single word
but
it is cool to see the president speak if
we have any respect left for the office
and it's dwindling by the day
then it is kind of cool and it'll
especially be cool for your parents and
grandparents and you should just suck it
up and go also because forget biden
forget your family for a second it's a
milestone in your life you might say
well college is worthless these days
well it's not exactly worthless but yes
i agree you don't get a great education
anymore it's extremely overpriced and
it's kind of a racket and yeah i grant
all of that i'm not defending college or
joe biden or even your family's desires
but you did go you did go to college and
it actually is a part of your biography
and therefore it actually is a big
moment in your life to graduate and
ritual is very important
as human beings putting our body into it
we don't just live on zoom we're not
just brains well increasingly we do
unfortunately but
we're not just brains floating in the
ether right we're not we we have bodies
we live in space we live in time and
you've got to do certain rituals and
you're going to look back on it and say
i remember my college graduation so i
would do that
from daniel
michael i've been a daily wire member
for well over a year and i am now one of
those new followers of you on twitter oh
thank you i know i've got a lot of them
now i couldn't tell if it was bots but
you don't seem like a bot you seem like
a real human
i've never had a twitter or even cared
about twitter i have a theory that the
reason for the uptick in followers for
conservatives has to do with more
conservatives joining twitter
conservatives now see a space where they
can get information without the big tech
overlords
and are now following all their faves
including yourself what are your
thoughts on that i think you might be
right at first i took a dimmer view a
more skeptical view and i said no it's
just all these bots flooding in
still might be some combination but just
the increase in engagement with real
people who are writing real things and
even with blue checks who are
theoretically verified humans i think
that very likely might be the case the
conservatives were shut out a lot of us
got extremely angry
when they kicked trump off we thought
that was so egregious so outrageous and
then furthermore uh twitter itself would
start banning conservatives for saying
innocuous things when elon was announced
as the new head of twitter
i just started tweeting out things you
previously weren't allowed to say
the 2020 election was obviously rigged
ivermectin's a wonder drug the the
public health authorities have lied to
us for two years i just tweeted those
things out and no no flags no censorship
no suspension and so i suspect a lot of
people who previously had their accounts
banned just came back on from jordan hey
michael i was born and raised in new
york
with the high crime rate insane taxes
and leftist lunacy is looking like it
might be time to move i'm wondering if
you have any suggestions on places in
the united states that would be good for
young adult conservative catholics
to live thank you very much
i do
it's called nashville tennessee that's
where i would recommend you go
head on over to nashville tennessee okay
one last question
from anonymous michael what drives the
culture of educators to think that it is
appropriate to share personal
information of any kind in the workplace
in any office space structured business
or corporation this type of behavior is
frowned upon to have a conversation with
a co-worker about a romantic
relationship is a great way to get sent
to hr in my occupation what does this
change in a school sincerely pre-order
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
you
know i'll go a little further on this
i am not convinced that it's always at
all times wrong for teachers to share
aspects of their personal life if you
call a teacher mrs smith you know that
she's married misses means you're
married okay so i know a lot of times we
want to say
that we don't want
teachers talking in any way about any of
their romantic relationships right but
that's not exactly true
we just don't want them talking about
the weird unusual creepy stuff and we
don't want them talking about the stuff
that is morally debatable and we don't
want them talking about the stuff that
huge huge swaths of the population view
with moral opprobrium and that
traditionally america is viewed with
moral program
this is why the argument of don't say
gay isn't really about lgbt it's about
it it could be don't say straight to no
that's not exactly right it's not
exactly right so i agree teachers
it's not that teachers need to
completely shut their mouths up and can
never mention that they even have a
husband teachers need to be appropriate
and appropriate implies standards and we
need to enforce traditional standards or
else we're going to get the wacko stuff
from the libs we're and we're going to
be transiting five-year-olds and that is
since you signed it
since you signed it with pre-order
speechless controlling words controlling
minds you know that is the thesis of my
book which is available now for order
and the paperbacks available for
pre-order i'm michael nolsas the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin